[Music]
YouTube week in partnership with library
continues this week and joining me today
is a stand-up comic a writer and an
actor
Yoko Dakar welcome to the Rubin
reporting of having me Dave glad to be
here you're looking sharp man thank you
it's not very stand-up is it the suit
and things like that I feel like I
should have come in just like a t-shirt
looking you're looking sort of old pro
standup oh wow not candy three year olds
okay but I just won't have the wisdom
that an old pro has not yet but I'm glad
you like the dress yeah very very I like
when a guest says I'm you know I'm not a
big show this thing's on the YouTube
thank you yes a great job being a fan
for a long time and I'm very happy to be
here
cool well I'm happy that you are here
and I look fan of yours as well thank
you thank you very much and there's a
lot that we're gonna talk about from
from stand-up to the videos you create
you live in Australia which is a far-off
I darius place for us american 15 our
flights geez yeah it's it's forward
right as it's a day forward in Australia
so when I'm talking to everyone I'm
talking to them in the future
Oh what you did you wouldn't think about
it cuz Australia is kind of sort
backward anyway so it's kind of an
oxymoron going on there yeah so this is
part of YouTube week what we're doing
here and I get to be when all these
youtubers this week I don't know that
you quite consider yourself a youtuber
but you consider yourself a stand-up
robably more than anything else right
that's see I used to be a really
skeptical skeptical of the term youtuber
because there was a certain stigma
attached to that because you generally
be associated with people who just do
pranks or vloggers but since then I've
kind of learned it and I thought yeah
I'm a youtuber because it's the medium
where I put out a lot of my content
which is comedy and short films but I'm
happy to be referred to as a youtuber
all right would you say stand up first
though if we were raised a comedian
first yes I think a lot of the writing I
do is very comedic even the acting it's
quite based in character comedy and
things like that so I just comedian yeah
so you came onto my radar about two
three years ago you did a video called
modern education yeah pretty much tore
up the internet yeah where did you get
the it we're gonna play a little clip
from it I static him but where did you
get the idea for this video modern edgy
well I was doing a lot of comedy as I
said and there seems to be this
pervasive idea of like what was good
comedy and there was like a lot of
social policing going around and I
always considered my comedy quite
progressive if anything I mean at face
value some of the jokes could be quite
broad aja sand in your face and
aggressive but underneath all that there
was an underlying message of you know
social liberalism basically but I
constantly got attacked for being racist
and sexist and I suppose I had my like
red pill moment then and yeah exercising
your white privilege exactly all right
like I'm clearly like I'm a white
nationalist I'm all of that and from
there I I didn't really look I wasn't
too interested in politics or anything
like that but I started to research a
bit more into it and and look into it a
bit more and and I sort of understood
the underlying cultural themes and ideas
that were you know contributing to this
kind of left-wing authoritarianism I'd
call it in I wanted to create something
that as you said told them apart because
I really I just didn't like that at all
and I've done a sketch a few months
earlier called hashtag equality you
might have seen that one as well that
one went quite well
my audience was very Australian prior to
that sketch so it was reaching an
audience here in North America and all
across the globe and and then I went
with modern education I really wanted to
go even deeper and try to not just sort
of say like hey look the left is
annoying in there they're LCCs or
whatever but I wanted to try to go
deeper a bit more and try to say like
that the emphasis on continued social
equity as the major aim is actually very
detrimental to just basic meritocracy
and that's probably the main message I
wanted to get across with modern
education I wanted to make it funny it's
quite a dark it's a very dark tone yeah
but you know I wanted to go for the
humor and the satire and I put it out
there and we were you know I mean my
friend Tim who I worked with on that
video and a lot of my other short films
we were skeptical as to how it would go
because it's the internet we thought you
know any video that doesn't get to the
punchline with
thirty seconds it's not gonna go well
yeah and this one there's no dialogue
for the first minute yeah and overnight
it got about twenty thousand views we
thought well that's quite good we're
happy with that
yeah then when we woke up Australian
time in the morning it had about 700,000
I think in a matter of hours it had
literally blown up and once you guys are
from the future over there so exactly
portend what was gonna happen yeah we
knew that was gonna you know we could
predict that and that week it just went
it went truly viral like I got millions
of views you got reuploaded on a lot of
Facebook pages we counted something like
20 million views all up when you take
into account the views on the YouTube
upload and all of the Facebook uploads
so it's very gratifying and there's a
lot of hate surrounding it okay we'll
get to the heat after so let's play a
little clip and and I just want to add
what was so beautiful about it was not
only because it was funny and because it
was poignant and relevant all that but
it was beautifully shot it wasn't
professional you know I try to put out a
professional show on YouTube and you
made a professional video on YouTube and
you see so many things that are just you
know webcam this or yeah silly graphic
this or that but you you actually made
saying that is really great I think we
talked it up enough let's throw out of
the clip
well done little bees you do Simon six
out of ten hey be careful you've been
staring at her for ten seconds what it's
a form of harassment to stare at a woman
for more than 15 seconds straight and
when I used to turn straight I don't
mean to offend any persons of a
non-traditional sexual preference and
when I used to turn non-traditional I
don't mean to offend any persons who
oppose historically normal eyes okay I
get it
unfortunately sunshine your research
assignment is only worth a word out of
10 I've used Fourier transform in
mathematical methods in the electronics
to analyze the electro diagrams of
at-risk patients and calculate their
risk of experiencing a heart attack I
mean it's a new method but it could
potentially save thousands of lives
seven you barely even read it you used
red pen what ready is considered
offensive in many religions why would
you belittle everything down to a
singular color
well Humanity is a rainbow of beauty and
spirituality yeah okay fine
seven out of ten but that still means I
get to go to the summit right the
marking process isn't over yet now
because we live in a society based on
equality the total amount of marks are
to be divided equally among our students
you've got to be kidding me
well that students we're all equal we're
all but then who gets to go to the
summit hi we haven't added our
privileged points yet don't you know
anything that is correct now never pee
you are females or that's passed one
privilege point
however you were white so that's minus
one I will do bisexual plus one that
leaves you with a total score of six out
of ten Simon unfortunately you're
straight white and male and cisgender
yes so that's minus four privileged
points which leaves you with a total
score of one so me fair now you your
mail and I don't like you so that's
minus two privileged points but you are
brown and sexually ambiguous so that's
plus two that leaves you with a total
score of five wait why am i sexually
ambiguous and finally sunshine I'm gay
I'm trans I'm Asian I'm overweight I'm
lower class I'm unintelligent
unattractive I've got hairs on my
nipples and I always caught body odor
and I can't really run properly or tie
my shoelaces by myself I once watched
the pigeon die wonderful sunshine that's
thirteen privileged points that leaves
you with a total score of 18 out of 10
well done sunshine you're going to New
York
sunshine you could do it let me see this
they've just written equality and drawn
love hearts on a piece of paper he
expressed himself and it's beautiful
he didn't even spell equality correctly
we don't discriminate he says nothing to
do with mathematics you think you're so
great with your maths and your signs and
your backs
what about feelings what about feelings
what does that mean that's the perfect
point to end it yeah what I like about
watching that with you is you still get
a kick out of it which out sometimes
it's hard to watch your own stand-up or
some of the things you produce yeah
usually we might stand up in other
sketches I find it a bit mmm a bit
disconcerting to watch but that one I
like I like it yeah yeah what's that
feeling like when something that you do
like kind of rips through something else
you like when it really actually makes a
mark it's very satisfying sorry sighs
well because that's what you want to
achieve as a
as a writer as any artist in general and
to just observe how well it went and to
see how many people caught on to it and
that it meant a lot to a lot of people
and it really resonated it's very
gratifying
what does it say that comedy is heading
in that direction because one of the
things I've noticed lately is that the
left unfortunately has sort of killed
comedy at least here in America and I
want to talk a bit about the Australian
scene as well but that what I find funny
these days is coming more so from the
right sort of the libertarian right
yes but the same people that are mocking
the same things that that you're going
after yeah I I agree and that's really
interesting because growing up you know
was the opposite yeah it was always the
left that were the the funny ones
basically because they were fighting
against the the authority yeah and now
the tables have turned essentially
because the left is kind of one the
culture war sorry to fight against that
is provocative were you worried at all
yeah will you worried though that you're
gonna put this out it goes against what
all the sort of norms are even accepted
just career-wise like the accepted like
oh I want to get the right agency to
pick me up and I want to get the
television show and all that but I'm
gonna do something that goes against the
very grain of what they sent as funny
even if it is funny you know yeah I was
very worried very well and especially
when it went really well to begin with I
was quite shy and a lot of institutions
were offering interviews and things like
that and I kind of backpedal and I
thought ah what's happening like what
have I done I've ruined my career
forever yeah but I like to think the
film itself is is quite accessible
because I think a lot of people on the
Left would also watch that film and say
that's true see I think I've what I've
done with it as I've created a picture
and like Illustrated an argument that
it's not just your typical like all the
left is stupid all the left is annoying
I've kind of gone a bit deeper than that
so it's it's not that easy to just kind
of dismiss it as like oh this is just
some right-wing trash yeah I like to
think anyway I did check yeah on the
Google today and what you said earlier
is true you did get a certain amount of
hate I did I saw articles written about
you yeah you know you're in it with the
all right I'm yeah I'm fine all right
that's naughty
insult any mother's makes you're not far
left so I'm just like yeah whatever I'm
all right like cool what was that like
yeah we could snip that and like ruin my
career just make sure you use all of
what I said before that it's all snip a
bow and the fact now you asked them to
do that means that they can't do that
that's sort of how it works I've ruined
it now now I'm OVA now you've really
ruined it what was it like though
getting that level of hate
it was surreal it was a bit I felt a bit
uneasy to begin with I had luckily I'd
had a big viral video a couple of years
ago within Australia that had achieved
like a million views in Australia within
a week which is like one you know five
percent of the population so I kind of
knew what I was dealing with bits
I just became a hermit for a week I
didn't really look at social media too
much Tim my friends in here now directs
a lot of the films he would kind of keep
me updated with what people are saying
and and and things like that i well i
backpedal backpedal a little bit which I
kind of regret right now I did these big
posts saying like hey look I'm a I'm a
centrist don't like bucks me in with the
riot and things like that which no I
kind of regret that because like I'm
giving in in a way but at the time when
older heat was coming on me I think that
was just like a natural response yeah
but they never stop right so you could
you could say that as many times I'm a
centrist I'm a good guy don't worry
Bobby well there's never enough that
they're like are he's cool he's cool
well they just throw out those like
labels so much that they've just lost
all meaning so I got like I said I don't
if people say like your race is still
like internalized racism or something
like that I'm just lying yeah yeah
doesn't affect me one of the things that
I thought was so cool about it was that
I I mean I didn't know who you guys were
beforehand but the fact that it came
from Australia I thought wow yeah the
stuff that I've been talking about that
so many people are talking about right
now that's just kind of bubbling up they
get it in Australia too and that means
how many other countries do they really
get it it's glow and then when I did a
little more research on you and I found
out that you're Indian and all that I
was like wow it does show that none of
this has to do with the immutable
characteristics that color your skin or
your sexuality or any of that it's what
it's what's right and what's wrong
that's it and that was
the beautiful moment for me which is why
I shared that thing like a thousand
times
it's about your opinions and your values
as a person and you know your skin color
or genders shouldn't matter I'm am I'm
not entirely dismissive of identity
politics I think there are some
conversations that identity politics is
relevant like particularly if you're
talking about issues that do affect
certain race or gender it does hold some
authority to say like hey look I am that
race I am that gender my opinion should
be given a certain level of authority
but this idea that like because you know
because I'm brown I'm only allowed to
talk about Brian issues and like a white
male is just not allowed to talk about
it I disagree with that
yeah if anything I think that's well
that's quite patronizing cuz it's the
the assumption is that like as a
minority I can't handle views that like
opposed mine and I'm such a snowflake
that like anyone that says anything
against me I'm gonna just crumble and
that's actually quiet
well it's discriminatory because it's
assuming that like I'm less like well
that's what a lot of people describe is
the soft bigotry of low expectations
exactly yeah
which is pretty depressing when a watch
how I'll use that to get to this next
question yeah I wasn't thinking of until
just now
okay but did you see that there's this
documentary now about a poo from from
The Simpsons I did say that yeah it's
called I think that the trouble with a
poo or yeah it's not something like that
but in effect basically saying that this
is somehow a bad stereotype and now
meanwhile everything in the Simpsons is
awful stereotype exactly the clown is
James the worst type of Harold a
stereotype but but the idea I haven't
seen the documentary yet I will watch it
maybe in my opinion will change after
but the idea of up who being offensive
or something they've taught so much
about Indian culture and had an Indian
wedding and yeah family and the children
and you've met his parents and the
episode where he's going to be deported
and he becomes the you know proud
American and shows Homer not to be a
bigot and all of this stuff it's like
man this is actually becoming racism
this is your coming what what did you
want them to do you know is a beloved
television character on probably the
greatest comedy
in modern times exactly I mean I do a
joke about that where I do say like it
is there's a bit of complexity to that
issue because I think as a growing up
like when up who is the only
representation of brown people that can
be quiet it's it's just it's not nice
and I used to be more like Oh get him
off the air like any sort of like
stereotypes like that are harmful but
I've sort of realized there's a bit more
nuance to that in that when you're in a
minority
you can't expect like everyone to kind
of bow down to you like you're in a
minor I'm understanding in Australia
like brown people are not like they're a
very small percentage of the population
so like not everything's going to like
revolve around us I do I do think like
the outrage that's happening now I mean
that was a show that came out in the 90s
so it would be different if they created
that character today that's
yeah like the whole outrage machine it
just doesn't it's it's like just just do
it then like the best way rather than
sort of complaining and saying like hey
change this change this to the people at
the top do something yourself you know
that was my philosophy like yeah I don't
like this like taxi driver kind of
character that much but I'm gonna show
that like not all Indians elect oh I'm
gonna do that myself and be an
individual and like I like to thing I've
done that you know there's not many
videos where I'm just like a very
stereotypical India I do make jokes
about that like don't get me wrong
particularly in my comedy I have all
sorts of you know Brown jokes in there
as I'm sure many people would know but
yeah that kind of like dependency and
and like sort of like demanding that
like you know this this character needs
to be taken down it's just it's not
empowering because you're saying like I
can't do it myself therefore someone
else has to like change that for me it's
also it's in a ratio of history don't
you think like even if they yeah if they
said alright well we're gonna what are
we gonna do we're gonna get rid of all
the episodes without without poo in it
so yeah what have we accomplished that
exactly No yeah and I think by watching
like those episodes and understanding
like that that look Indians like we love
a race of racial joke more than anyone
you know if it's done properly and if
it's done right I love up whoo I think
he's hilarious yeah yes so like I just
started who loves the kwik-e-mart
probably the best song in the history of
the Simpson exactly I just remember that
where's like howling to the degree I
mean that and that whole episode is
about immigration and getting Homer to
stop being so against immigration I mean
exactly
yeah when you put the lens of today's
like social values onto something that
it was even like relevant thirty years
ago
it just doesn't it's not it's it's not
fruitful yeah so I actually I don't know
too much about your background are you
second-generation yeah I'm sick I
depends what you I might even be third
it's like Oh folks the the first
generation my mother's parents came to
Australia in the 60s and then my dad
came in the 80s so I'm like second and a
half generation or something like that
I'm not sure yeah that could also affect
the privilege of the way yeah I know
right yeah I'm not a first generation
immigrants sorry I don't get all the
rewards is there a big Indian community
yeah yeah I mean there's a big in the
Indian community all over the world the
poorest areas I'm pretty sure there's a
big one in Sydney when my grandparents
came there wasn't actually and
ironically enough like when the Indian
cricket team would tour Australia they'd
go to my grandparents house and like
crickets like a huge industry and in
India and like I I heard that I was
extremely jealous when I heard that but
yeah that's my background but like my
parents are pretty westernized I just
speak English I don't actually speak
Indy or Marathi which is like the local
dialect for where my parents are from my
dad speaks my mom doesn't even speak
yeah so I'm basically just Australian
there's like remnants of like the Indian
culture that have sort of comes through
with my parents but I wouldn't call me I
quote myself like racially little ask
you about boomerangs and kangaroos and
all that unique perspective you find you
have a lot of fans in India though
because I get a ton of email from people
in India that are so aware of that free
speech issues yeah that word that we're
talking about that you're making videos
about things like that I do and it's
surprising that it happens but I have a
quite expensive fan base in India
biggest is Australia but as you said
like knowing that these issues are so
relevant all across the world
it's incredible cuz you always think
you're the only one you know around all
your friends think particularly in
Germany in particularly like I I always
say like I am somewhat biased because I
think the arts industry and particularly
people my age generally you know very
left-leaning and things like that
whereas if I was in finance or something
like that maybe I don't know maybe I
would change but you do feel like you
know like you can't really say some
things that you want to say and things
like that so to know that like there's
this global connection of people that
have come together as you call like the
new center it's nice yeah that's good
tonight it's pretty cool all right let's
shift to stand up a little bit okay so
you told me right before we started you
started doing stand-up when you were 15
I did 15 yeah I did the best I know I
was I was a class clown one of those
guys and I do my first gig at 15 and
like a lot of comedians will say oh my
first gig was terrible and things like
that mine actually went really well it
was my second gig that was horrendous
because like I did this competition for
high school students in Australia and I
did very well at that and then this
talent show that was lack around this
acting school I was doing more like a
you're a comedian come come to comedy
come to stand-up at this talent show and
I have to follow a four year old girl
playing the flute which is like that's
important you can't do that like I come
out there like hey how you guys do it
and like it was next to a church sorry I
did these kind of religious jokes that
didn't go well at all and it was
probably the West and still to this day
as the West king of Avadh so I kind of
had probably the bow your biggest bomb
was your second gig is my second gig
ever yeah yeah
isn't it funny like I remember doing my
first gig ever my first time on stage
and it's like you don't even know how to
screw up so I think most comics usually
think of their first one was pretty good
because like you don't know how to mess
up at that point you're just it's off
like pure adrenaline then you can go
through a phase where it's like this
suddenly got a lot rougher yeah you've
got nothing to lose there's no pressure
on you and you don't know the ins and
outs of comedy and you don't know what
constitutes a good bit versus just like
hey I got lost that means I did well
yeah where is now like this sermon you
know you feel the weight of all the like
comedians judging you even when they're
not in the room I always like oh will
they like that bit will they like that
bit which is not the best mind
to have but they said we want the cop
it's natural yeah exactly so you did you
consistently do it then until you were
18 or did that kind of shut you down for
a bit it did shut me down for a little
bit I did one or two gigs when I was
like 16 17 and my parents were always
lying just finished high school to do
that but I was always I was really
adamant that I wanted to be a comedian
and I wanted to get into entertainment
so when I finished high school I took a
gap year and I actually I came to LA as
like an 18 year old oh yeah I did like
an open-mike at The Comedy Store here
and I died pretty badly mics are pretty
their own winery I know right but like I
can say I look up from the Comedy Store
when I was 18 that's kind of cool I did
a few gigs around Australia I started
getting known around the scene and then
I just kind of yet built my way up as
you do well yeah how long did it take so
you were making your full living well it
didn't take long I was very lucky
because of the internet I was able to
kind of cultivate an audience online and
then generate that into you know paying
audience members to shows and and then I
was able to film some of that stand up
and get it online so people knew I
wasn't just like the kid in his bedroom
making vlogs that's how I started yeah I
was just like a teenager in my bedroom
just yelling and I like to think I've
grown a bit from there and yeah so I was
lucky I didn't I didn't really have to
take too long I don't know if that's a
good thing though because I didn't have
to like tough it out for like years on
end in the clubs and I feel like the
comedian's that do that are generally
better but like at the same time if I
was doing that now enough I was toughing
it out I'll probably just be like oh I
wish I kind of had my own audience yeah
that's it that's a really interesting
piece of being an artist though right
like that you need that struggle for a
certain amount of time so you can get
that all into a piece of into a diamond
yeah but I'm pretty sure having a little
you know not a little having a nice
share of success that you have now is
probably better for like long-term
health of all life you know yeah in that
sense yeah financial health and just
like mental well-being it probably is
better you can afford a nice suit yeah
this was not very expensive right thank
you I'm glad it gives off that
impression yeah appreciate that we're
gonna show a little bit of your standup
right
see this is one where I don't know if I
want to walk you can leave the room if
you like I almost I almost emailed you
yesterday to say what clip if we're
gonna show a clip what should we show I
can't I thought that might dip it off a
little bit much because I wanted a real
reaction of something that that I did
let's say so let's watch Neal in action
America to me is like the really tall
handsome guy in high school that's just
good at everything but he [ __ ] knows
it like he'll be walking around the
hallway or cocky like hey what's up
Bolivia
what's up stray Lanka Sri Lanka's like
oh my god he knows my name and he'll be
friends with you but if you so much as
look at him the wrong way he goes nuts
like if you're some little country in
the hallway that's like I'm America
you're your shoelace is untied he's like
huh who said that you you which what's
your name bro what's your [ __ ] name
um ha Lichtenstein yeah okay you listen
to me dick tan Stein yeah you see these
weapons of mass destruction if you so
much as look at me the wrong way again I
will [ __ ] you up and let's be honest as
Australia we're kind of like a dumb best
friend that's like [ __ ] you up
shut up Australia New Zealand's off to
the side like ye suck on beach
I'm pretty sure if North Korea was a kid
in high school he'd be the strange kid
that no one really talks to and and
America is always trying to find out
what's in his locker he's always like
what's in your locker North Korea yo
come on open up
show me North Korea is always like
ramier on America but they just keep
trading blows with each other like hey
North Korea what's it like sucking your
Supreme Leader's two inch asian dick
every night hey America right don't you
ask you're my god oh that's it you're
[ __ ] dead bro and America pulls out a
gun obviously but luckily Canada's there
and he's like no America let's talk
about her feelings what's your problem
Canada no I think you're the one with
the problem America Chyna's starting to
beat you in exams in sport and and you
can't handle the fact you're no longer
as dominant well what what are you
talking about I'm still dominant hey hey
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go
steal Jordans lunch money and Australia
is gonna come with me won't you
Australia off [ __ ] yeah let's guy might
oh are you are you drunk
Australia oh my god England Australia's
drunk again for goodness sake I cannot
believe he's still part of the bloody
Commonwealth why can't you be more like
New Zealand yes
[Music]
so I'm a bit more bashful with my
stand-up yeah well I was gonna say just
watching even your body language that
yeah yeah the way like oh [ __ ] shy with
the standup I don't know why I was this
figure that's just the way it is I think
we're overly critical as comedians of
our own material yeah whereas I don't
know with the show film I'm just like
yeah cool
what's the stand-up scene like in
Australia well it's it's it's good it's
it's a lot smaller than in America and
like people in general don't have the
same stand-up knowledge that I think
they do even just your average punter in
America or in the UK we do this thing
called festivals so every year
Australian comedians come up with an
hour and they perform it at festivals
around the major cities in Australia and
that's like the did stand-up scene
revolves around those festivals and if
you can make it in those festivals then
like TV producers and and like
executives start oh that's the guy
that's the guy who did that great
festival show and then you get on TV or
you get on radio and then you make it
whereas lately that's been changing a
little bit now like there's a few
comedians doing it through the internet
like I'd probably be one of the first to
do that mm-hmm and I think that's a lot
more empowering to be honest you don't
have to appease like the people up the
top and you don't have to like change
your your comedy or anything like that
so you're truly your own boss right now
yeah that's great I'm pretty sure you
are as well like it's a really good
position to be and sometimes you fall
into the trap of looking at people on TV
and radio and you think like well you
know what I'm doing is so much better
wave and they like put me there but then
when you sort of take a step back and
realize that like hang on I'm like I
have like full artistic control over
what I do and I've been doing a few
things on TV in Australia which is
exciting but it's really good to know
that like I don't need that and so that
gives me a lot of freedom I think like I
can sort of do those shows but still
like come on in
you know show like this say what I want
and then I'm not too worried like about
what's going to happen cuz like if I
could I lose that doesn't matter right
you're not gonna fire yourself after
this right exactly no I don't think so I
have to go a half hour left
right black dude those American success
mean anything - Australian comics like
really breaking through and like you're
saying you own it now it's on the
Internet
you have I'm sure many fans in the
states as well as all over the world
yeah but it's like the idea of oh I want
to get on The Tonight Show in the United
States does that up meaning yeah yeah
there's a few Australian comedians that
have managed to get on The Late shows
here in America and there they come back
and they treated like gods in Australia
Jim Jefferies is an Australian comedian
who's he didn't really even make it in
Australia he when he was I think in his
early 20s he moved to the UK and then
moved straight to America and he's huge
he's huge in America he's huge in
Australia as a result he cups a lot of
criticism for his material and things
like that but no American success is the
pinnacle for success even in Australia
like everyone wants to make it in
America what do you think it is about
Australians that's so against the PC
culture because I know just from the
couple Australians that I've had on this
you know Andrew Bogut the NBA player I
mean you can't get athletes to say
anything these days yeah came on and he
was I was like is there anything you
don't want to talk about he was like
we'll do it all maybe right now he's in
LA so I wanna I want to get him actually
in studio yeah also he fit in this chair
right we made the move I was like do you
know Rita Panahi yeah who I absolutely
adore I've had on the show like just
relentlessly against political
correctness yeah do you think that's
really built into Australians I know you
guys are struggling also yeah some of
this regressive nonsense though why
supposedly Australia was always built as
the like working man's paradise and like
it was convicts from England and and I
think generally the culture in Australia
is probably a bit more like blue colour
than like say America the UK so as a
result they don't like doesn't bode well
with kind of like high-minded
pretentiousness and that's I think the
the kind of like modern left and
political correctness has that air about
them right very self-righteous and
levitating above like everyone sir
Australians are very quick to like cut
people down if they think that you know
ahead of themselves that this thing
called told poppy syndrome in Australia
so if anyone if we feel like anyone's
you know a bit too full of themselves
and has developed a bit of an ego we're
really quick to just like shut them down
and that ties into our sense of humor
it's quite dry and I think that's why
yeah a lot of Australians are against
that like incessant political
correctness we're also like relatively
socially liberal country like we just
passed gay marriage finally like I'm in
favor of that and everything so it's not
as though we're like some backward like
a backward it down like it doesn't give
rights to people at all but I think most
Australians know the difference between
like just you know being nice to people
and and the rights that people do
deserve versus like the crazy kind of
like political correctness that tend to
get conflated I always think there must
be something really nice about being in
a giant geographic area that's
completely surrounded by water you guys
must have a certain security because of
that Alright isolated I don't know if we
have maybe yeah apparently we're in the
firing line of North Korea right now so
I don't know it's two here in LA yeah
that's turnout like that everyone is so
yeah I mean it's the land it's the land
that like everyone kind of forgot about
them like even our wildlife and
everything it's completely different
it's been isolated from the rest of the
world for so long so yeah it's great to
like it's very proud I'm very proud to
like be like yeah mr. Allen because it's
so far away from everywhere as well and
whenever you see Australians Make It in
America or anywhere across the globe you
you you know you're very proud of that
you guys love karaoke do we yeah I
didn't know that I was funny before I
had some Australians living on the other
side of me what I live I can't go there
part of town doing karaoke I have an
oven coat onto that train yeah alright
maybe that was Japanese people terrible
at karaoke you know did you ever do that
like what are you talking about I can't
sing that because I'll do it I could
maybe like do you like hip hop karaoke
but that's about it did you ever do like
dance dance revelution not good at it I
dance like I'm good at that I'm good at
that yeah I can do that but I like the
karaoke not useless yeah
you're big gamer too okaycome called
myself a big gamer but like any I guess
male uh-huh in today's day and age
I played video games in my adolescence
and I was talking to you about this
before very loyal to the PlayStation
franchise yeah big PlayStation guy had
the ps1 that was my first console and
then loved the ps2 I think that's the
best console of all time hands down some
people say this Ness but like you know I
like the ps2 and well you made me feel
right before we started because you
pointed to that Sega Genesis that was
before my time man I didn't say old man
it was it was invited eyes singer Don I
was a sonic right sonic was on Sega
Genesis Sonic was a little bit of Sega I
did get a Nintendo way for a while and I
was just like not don't like this so I
went back to the ps3 and I got a ps4 and
like I'm sure when the PS 5 comes out
I'll get that - you'll get that - yeah
all right let's shift back to Australia
that was a slight desert what are like
the hot button issues going on in
Australia right now are you guys talking
Trump all the time yeah is it as
obsessed with Trump they like Webb
suddenly become really interested in
American politics like we never were
privyet we'd know like Obama and things
like that but ever since Trump came on
the scene like everyone has an opinion
on him even in Australia when like I
think because we're part of just like
the general like Western group of
Nations from still would have some sort
of a flow-on effect to Australia so yeah
everyone in Australia is talking about
the same things people in America are
talking about maybe not to the same
extent like we have our own things in in
sport that are happening in the same way
like the things in sport are happening
here everything's kind of the say
there's like the big cultural divide
it's probably not as extreme as in
America because the the the far-right in
Australia it's kind of it's building up
a little bit like the populist right so
there's a lady called Pauline Hanson who
she's in charge of a party in Australia
called the one nation party and
ironically enough in the 90s she was a
member of parliament and then she was
always known as a bit racist and things
like that and then she kind of went off
the scene she actually went to jail the
sack I remember was some tax thing I
don't know exactly
and then last election she won four
seats in the Senate so she's made a big
comeback but I think that's a real
indication of the way the like culture
is going like if someone here in the
night
could only when one Satan mic was
dismissed as like this crazy old person
is now winning flawless eight
something's going wrong you know and we
see that happening all over the West
happening at you know the pen although
she lost
yeah and Gert will ders in in AB Street
in Holland everyone yeah so what can we
do then so for guys like us that have
you know a little bit influence that we
have that one I think the reason I do
this is probably similar to the reason
you do what you do it's like yeah I want
to fix this stuff I want them all I want
the Liberals to be liberal again and all
that yeah what can we do besides make
make fun of it in your case and talk
about in my case I mean what do you
think look I'm on the side of comedy I
think comedy is really important and I
think how many needs to be careful that
it doesn't tread down an activist path
because a lot of activism seems to be
completed as comedy these days
particularly with some of the comedians
in Australia they're just like I've
always thought with with stand-up like
it yeah being like the good punchlines
are important but it's like what are you
actually saying in the bit and like a
good bit for me is like has it changed
my thinking on something and a lot of
the comedians that come out and just say
these like opinions that like I agree
with but like it's the same opinion you
get in like a BuzzFeed article yeah
you're not offering anything different
so I do think comedy and art is really
important and I think being like as
unbiased as possible so I try to watch
as much like left and right leaning
content as much as possible I really try
to keep an open mind I try not to be as
dismissive of I used to be more
dismissive if the left and be like oh
they're just crazed they're all social
justice warriors and I'm trying now to
like understand a bit more about like
structural racism and things like that I
still don't necessarily agree with all
of it but I think it's worth like
listening to that point of view and
maybe not dismissing it entirely but at
the same time I think you know people on
the Left have to not just dismiss
conservatives as like I just like Hicks
or whatnot sorry about listening to
people and like doing what you can as an
individual being nice to people and
presenting your opinions but in a you
know in a nice way and but also like not
being afraid to say what you think and
speak your mind and not judging people
for are you shocked as a 23 year old the
amount
young people that are afraid to say what
they think yeah it's someone that says
what they think for a living yeah I know
it's it's so much like this mob it's
like this group mentality well like I
have to say if I say the right things
people will like me and that's the
antithesis of what comedy is supposed to
be about I mean like look I struggle
with that as well like I will go to a
gig that's like an inner-city room like
full of like hipsters and things like
that and I'll be like alright this is
the bit I'm gonna do I'm gonna do this
bit about like I don't know like
football players or like outrage culture
and then as soon as I do like I get like
one minute into the bit I'm like nah
they're not going to like all right
what's like hey I'm Brown like just like
transition back into that straightaway
sorry it's easier said than done
in this climate to be as honest as
possible like but I think we got to
strive to be that and you know try to do
the best we can yeah do you think that
the the cellphone changed comedy in a
way I guess really when you started
pretty much everyone had the phone
already yes I know when I started when
no one had cell phones I started in 98
and the club was like a very private
place you can work out your [ __ ] you
could you could bomb or kill and it
didn't matter in terms of the outside
world it matters for you yeah but I
remember when the phone started creeping
in and like I guess the early 2000s and
that people would start videotaping and
then I'd be staring at the guy that's
videotaping me the whole time right and
then worried eventually when YouTube
came out they're gonna put that on there
and I just you know I said one thing
wrong or just the joke didn't work or or
even if it did work I didn't want the
joke out publicly yet like a series of
reasons that it really changed but were
you even doing stand-up before probably
not right before so you might have
filmed me I don't know I probably
haven't observed that same like
paramount difference because I don't
know what it was like before cell
friends as you said I still do like what
I do with the clubs and it's important
to fail because like the bits that like
fail to begin which means you're saying
something that like people might not
necessarily like and then if you can
like add the punch lines that make it
receptive and like to people I think
that's a very powerful bit so I try to
just like ignore the the cell phone
thing and just kind of go there and do
my stuff and hopefully people laugh if
it goes online
like I'm probably not a huge comedian so
like if someone post like a thing online
it's not gonna like ruin my career but I
don't like what Dave Chappelle like
before his specialist came out someone
had posted one of them in full yeah
online so it's a it's a hot-button issue
I don't know how we're gonna prevent
that unless like with Chris Rock what he
did in his shows he's like you'd put
your cell phones in like a pouch before
the show but that just seems like
needlessly expensive for the promoter so
I'm not sure like what the answer to
that is right right not everybody can
afford the guy that's going around with
the pouch yeah exactly so I think you
just gotta stay true to like your bit
and still like say it and do it and if
people don't like it or if people are
like I would like because a lot of
people will say like you know Chris Rock
or someone famous at a club and they'll
be like well they weren't that funny at
the club and I'm like yeah because they
were like no practicing you know that's
like that they're not doing their best
bit like they're just working out that
bit right there
if someone I'm skeptical of a comedian
that like every time they get up there
they just get like infinite laughs
because then they're not trying anything
like different
I remember once one of my first Road
gigs I truly don't remember the guys
name but this guy was like a true road
comic yeah you know what I mean like
couldn't have improv his way out of a
wet paper bag but like he knew his act
he knew the 45 minutes he had repeated
it for jillion times yeah and he was
pretty good yeah but like not great but
pretty good but I remember thinking
after I was like this is actually kind
of depressing because this guy he's got
this thing he can't explore anymore
because he's making his living on the
road when you're making a living on the
road you can't explore you got to
explore probably when you're in Sydney
or you know one of the big cities well
the environment around you yeah right
but you can't explore your heart yeah
that's like the the that's the artists
nightmare I guess yeah as soon as a
comedy becomes like a rehearsal
I when I started it was probably a bit
more like that for me because I wanted
to be an actor more than anything so I
dried my material out word-for-word
practice it like 10 times now it's just
about like this is the thought I want to
get out there this is the punchline I'd
like to get to let's just go to the club
and see how it goes and I think that's
very it's very powerful because people
respond to people who were just
themselves onstage know like comedy is
the is
the complete opposite of acting is
acting it's all about immersing yourself
into like another character to the point
where you've forgotten about yourself
whereas I think with comedy in my lack
you know limited experience having done
it it's about just finding your voice
and like that can take years as simple
as it sounds to like be the comedian you
want to be on stage and be so
comfortable that you can just get up
there and don't be nervous and just be
yourself yeah that's the ultimate goal
for any comedian I remember I took an
acting class for maybe six months or a
year or something many years ago yeah
and I remember thinking there was such a
fundamental difference between comics
and actors yeah actors wanted to be
someone else yeah and comics wanted to
be themselves yeah they both come with a
series of different flaws and if you
know different character traits or
whatever but I remember thinking like I
for me personally I did not like acting
I was like why would I want to act like
somebody else I was trying to like
figure out my [ __ ] yeah so that I could
make it the funniest or do I guess what
I'm doing right now yeah I agree with
that like I sing when I started I wanted
to do both and like jump in and out of
us and be like this big star that like
is in movies but also does like amazing
sellout stand-up shows in and then I
realized like the two crafts are very
different so I think you could do both
but I don't think you could be very good
at both there are exceptions I like
Robin Williams out there are definitely
guys that can do a but it's very
difficult because like as we've just
discussed like they're two different
goals yeah well you look at a guy like
yeah you look at a guy like George
Carlin who I would say is probably the
best standup of all time yeah and none
of his acting things really ever no I
had a couple funny little things and
billiards and a few other things but it
was it was really about his status they
never won an Oscar or anything
he was a white male so I couldn't happen
well he's an interesting example
actually of if he was doing college gigs
these days he'd be the type of guy that
they'd be protesting he's a white guy
who would be calling out this PC
[ __ ] yeah and he already did in the
90s he would call out call it out then
it was well ahead of his time my the guy
that I look up to the - Chris Rock sorry
from when I was a kid like I just loved
Chris Rock I thought he was the most
funny like he's just the funniest guy
like on the planet and then as I gotten
older and like lent more about the craft
to stand-up I can just see
how carefully like crafted his bits are
and how amazing he really is as a
stand-up because he could just sort of
intertwine all these like kind of like
over-the-top black jokes with like a
really poignant social point that's why
you have always loved Creed and he can
also sort of like transition between
like he's a very mainstream kind of guy
but is knowing among the comedy scene is
like one of the greats and yeah he's the
guy for me
yeah I always think it's particularly
interesting with black comics too like
there's such a beautiful through line of
evolution of how the story evolved like
yeah they had Dick Gregory than they had
Bill Cosby than they had Chris Rock and
Chappelle yeah whoever it is now and of
course they're all doing things that are
very daddy Murphy well I'll do things
that are very different a lot of them
didn't like each other and had very good
fights or like they all told a certain
story in a different way and it like I
think you can make a direct argument
that a lot of led to ultimately one day
having a black president here in the
United States
definitely and that was what like comedy
that was what comedy can be really
powerful as like a tool for like social
change which is what it's meant to be
and I think a lot of the community that
I think they're doing that but it's
Leslie ah like they're just they're just
being activists I like as much as I
might agree with the opinions they
espouse onstage it's just not it's not
funny it's not a comedy they're not
saying anything different and there are
so many that have turned me off from
Twitter I mean yeah I mean like as soon
as they're saying things like you know
how dare this person well is yeah
exactly it's your role that's your job
to be funny yeah I'm not trying to say
like I'm perfect about it like I'm like
this is very for the most part of being
quite seriously this interview lack I'm
not like the difference between like
being cut funny and like like a clown
kill you yeah I've lost it there's a
difference between being like a comedian
and a good satirist and just being like
a clown who just comes on it's like look
at me like I'm funny all the time but
yeah as soon as you become like
self-righteous in comedy you go to you
go to sort of look at yourself
that's how not to because sometimes when
you're trying to get an opinion out
there you got to really tiptoe that line
between being preachy and sort of doing
it subtly and I think that's like again
like I'm still very new to the game I
don't know like maybe in another five
years I'll change completely and be like
you know what those activist committed
alright somehow I feel like you're not
going the activist route the harpes I
will say yeah what do you think about
the idea that comments need a certain
amount of pain that you know it comes
from pain well I think all artists have
some sort of darkness in their life
that's why I want to do this bit about
like I don't think I can ever be that
great a comic because I don't have to
instead of darkness that like these
other guys have yeah I think there's a
limit I can't reach like all the great
musicians and everything like that like
they've the 27 club in in music like I
think having that pain on having that
cynicism is really important because it
gives you that like perspective of
looking around at everyone around you
and saying like this is all stupid like
what we're doing the world we live in
it's all it's all funny to me
you're whereas if you're just like a
normal happy person like you don't
necessarily have that perspective so I
do think it's important I don't think
it's essential but I think every every
comedian as you know had something
they're trying to prove or some kind of
like insecurity or validation I think
for me it was just like in high school I
just probably wasn't that popular and
then like as a lot of male comedians
just probably wanted to get laid that's
how it started off with me and then
since then it's just it's changed a
little bit I do really like the craft
and I just want to like hone in on that
skill and like I'm very young I'm 23 so
like most comedians don't peak until
they're in their 30s at least so I'm not
trying to say like I'm the best by any
means but I just like to progress like
each kind of show that I film and put
out there I'd like to say like hey that
one was a bit better than the one before
and continue doing what I'm doing and
yes I love that spirit though because
you're right stand-up is one of the few
careers and I think perhaps maybe what
I'm doing now where the older we're
gonna get hopefully we'll get better at
it I always think that I look back
probably in five years from now I'm
being like [ __ ] a lot better yeah 100%
and like something like acting you can
do that but like it's it's so much
determine on your look and like how you
can be cast where as yeah like a stand
up what you're doing right writing in
general those are timeless careers that
like that you usually the older you get
the better you get
yeah by the way I don't know if you
noticed but a minute ago when you said
something about stand-ups having a
certain amount of pain that light right
there flicked at that
very moment well maybe I do have that
pain and just like you don't know what's
what's within me like no I knew what
like louis c.k was doing behind the
scenes right obviously if you ask him if
he has any pain he's not gonna be like
yeah if I really do have something doc
maybe I'm just not saying it who knows
perhaps yeah all right so since we're
doing this for YouTube week let's talk a
little bit about some of your
frustrations yeah YouTube creator um
I think definitely the ad pocalypse
that's frustrated me quite substantially
as it has with a lot of YouTube creators
I'm lucky enough that I don't rely
entirely on YouTube for my income it's
actually just a nice little cash cow
that I can keep so it hasn't like
completely being of detriment to me as
of yet but there's been a huge drop in
earnings which is very frustrating I
kind of get it from the perspective of
YouTube as a big corporation they do
wonder what pays advertisers but at the
same time the thing that frustrates me
the most as with a lot of creators
particularly in our circle is like the
double standard that they have in that
like this content is inappropriate but
this content is fine and it's like
what's the actual policy like what do
you there's no like real clear-cut
evidence of like what are the videos
that will get D monetize them what are
the ones I want it's just an algorithm
so like depends on the keywords and
things like that and then you can do the
manual review but like if it's gone
viral and if it's achieved a million
views in like a day then like what do
you do you know it's it is very
frustrating but I think it's been
empowering to an extent for a few
creatives because they've found other
outlets so patreon for example I'm on
patreon now as well I do a few like
branded content type videos that helps
me out a fair bit and would stand up
that's my main kind of thing another
frustration I'd have is like just a
label youtuber because like I think now
it's definitely changing but when I
started there was a huge stigma attached
with anyone who was like a youtuber was
like oh you just do cat videos or like
you're just a prankster you can't do
anything and that was probably a big
motivation as to why I've made a film
like modern education so I wanted to say
like I know like we're not just we're
not useless yeah like we can create
professional good content
now with the emergence of people like
you and just there's a huge array of
YouTube channels that I watch that just
they're better than mainstream me if
anything now its mainstream media that
are the ones that are like oh how do we
get the most like views within this
short space of time like Australian TV
right now it's just all reality TV it's
Tara it's just literally all of it is
reality TV because it's just like hey
this rates and like we can create like
so many hours of content yeah and
there's no room for anything like a bit
different anything a little bit like
pushing the boundaries whereas like
YouTube has that because you're not
beholden to like the big director or the
boss or like the advertisers so you can
you can be free and like I guess the
other thing that happens is like you get
a huge range in the quality of content
so with YouTube you get a huge amount of
videos that are just like pranking and
just like you know terrible but then you
get like some of the most amazing
content that you wouldn't get in the
mainstream media context because that
would have to be filtered through all
these producers and so many different
like eyes would have to look at it it's
funny this week alone from doing this
YouTube Week thing where I'm talking to
five creators yes like I've watched a
lot of the stuff all of the stuff from
you and everyone else that I've had on
I'm like man there are really talented
people out there yeah I don't remember
the last time I watch television and
thought hey these are talented people if
anything I think these are the worst
types of people or deeply untalented
people or nervous I'm curious though on
on a video like modern education you
don't have to give me the numbers
obviously but that was you obviously put
real money into that and your cameras
were great and sound was great and I'm
sure you paid your actors and all that
stuff it was that did you make a dime on
that thing at the time that was before
apocalypse yes I'm a likely but you know
the YouTube revenue did actually make a
profit in the end on it and because it's
like it's a continuous income so it's
still going mmm finally enough modern
education hasn't been demonetised it
never got demonize and Hannity monetize
equality I think it has or its bit like
when you type in equality in YouTube
hashtag quality doesn't come up in the
results but the films haven't been
denied because like I think with modern
education there's no words in the title
or there's nothing that really
there's no swearing in it there's no
actual like obvious like really adult
themes per se so I think parenting
monetizing it would be a big story if
they D monetize that I think not just
myself but a few people would be like no
hang on like this is not like there's
nothing really that incendiary about one
education at face value so I'd be pretty
upset if they did D monetize that a lot
of my earlier videos when I was doing
kind of like the more like lowbrow like
Ozzie kind of video is there got D
monetize Farah now there's like a lot of
swearing in the bits well actually I
have to thank my actors of my cast and
crew you know infinitely because like at
the time I I think a lot of them did
volunteer so you know I realized as
always I think I said I'm sure you know
they wanted the experience yeah that
great - it wasn't slave labor yeah
completely presumptuous of me to say you
all listen if I had a nickel now for
every free gig that I did over the years
exactly yes oh yeah look what I started
I didn't have a lot like I love to spend
on the production and things like that
and luckily it was a young cast and crew
of like-minded people that just wanted
to create something and a lot of them
had like their part-time jobs and things
like that so I said hey do you want to
be a part of this it'll generate this
many views minimum and a lot of them
just said yeah that's cool but now we do
have a patreon and yeah I do pay the
actors cast and crew yeah so you became
a businessman - I did yeah what like
could stand up to running from the real
world and yeah smack in the middle of it
we're supposed to be making fun of them
I know like well don't we you ever make
fun of me all the business man I should
I should be able to but like then I'm
making fun of myself and I don't know I
yeah I'm a businessman now and I like it
I like the freedom and I never saw
myself as being able to hold like a
nine-to-five office job with someone you
know telling me what to do I don't think
that just doesn't suit me I don't think
anyone likes it I particularly I just
don't think that was conducive to my
personality at all so that's the beauty
of the Internet it allows people to be
truly entrepreneurial yeah
and I think when there's that
individualism that like entrepreneurial
spirit that can only be good for
whatever it is you do whatever business
it is you're part of or whatever it is
that you produce I can only be a good
thing yeah do you ever worry that we're
just too beholden on a few too many a
few too many companies like we're pretty
beholden on YouTube we are behold into
Twitter yeah out into Facebook and at
some point even if modern education
didn't get any monetize you never know
when that speak it's gonna turn
something I don't want to think very
much yeah what do you do I mean it's the
outlet that is there right now and I'm
sure if those went away or if they
became more filtered and went as free
and liberating with what content they
allowed you to post another outlet would
come up just the market will like adapt
and there'll be another platform that
comes out that allows people to be truly
free and already like Facebook is in
competition with YouTube's they're
trying to be like a legitimate video
platform and I suppose when YouTube
became bit more professional in trying
to compete with TV networks with like
the monetization and like really polite
pushing up the content creators that
weren't that we're you know offering
something a bit more then Facebook came
along with these really quick videos and
like vines were really popular on
Facebook and they kind of took that
market of like they're like really just
like fast food type videos and now
Facebook a try and it like they're
monetizing a few videos but I always
skip a video times I just can't watch it
so like I guess they're in competition
with each other so I don't know if one
of them like I think they're going to
kind of keep themselves in check yeah
how do you hear a free market guy yeah
I'm a very free market kind of guy tour
next day I think that obviously should
be some kind of regulation I'm not like
a complete capitalist by any means but
yeah definitely I think the free market
is like the best tool we have in like 80
to 90% of the time it's incredibly
effective and it's going to create the
most efficient outcome
well said where does this all go in 10
years where is
just me personally Oh where's this whole
operation go like if it all goes out are
you are you the number one standup in
the world
hopefully you want to aim for that I'd
like to be that I'd like to just keep
growing and keep posting the content I
want to post and I'm lucky enough to be
in a financial position where I'm very
comfortable I'm not rich by any means
but it's never been about money for me
sometimes money can be tempting I'm not
gonna lie like occasionally like a TV
network or something will come along
with a big offer and you know once or
twice I was like who I'm interested and
then I got to the final two but then I
didn't get it and then I thought oh that
was a bit of a blessing in disguise cuz
you see the person who did get it in
there just it's terrible yeah it's nice
though having that luxury right you're
not asked for have to take it absolutely
it's really the latter already now I'm
doing I think I mentioned that before
I'm doing a few TV things and I can just
sort of sit back and say like cool let
them do that like if they want to come
to me that's fine in 10 years yeah I'd
like to just be as good a stand-up as I
possibly can be I'd like to move into
feature films eventually that would
there's a whole kind of like economic
argument to that as well because I got
to find the funding whether or not I go
like the Netflix route and things like
that
I'm not too sure how I'll do that but
that is a goal I'd like to create some
feature films and longer series not just
short films but that's that's more of a
long-term goal I would like to bridge
that divide between mainstream media and
the internet because there seems to be a
bit of they're like you know I've
displayed that as well of like well
those dumb like mainstream media kind of
thing like yeah that chasm is still kind
of big it is it is and I think slowly
very gradually it's it's decreased but
like the to me like TV always tends to
pluck out the worst internet creators
and continue that stigma of like just
yeah no one on YouTube is doing anything
serious you know they'll bring out the
pranksters or like the you know the the
girls who just do vlogs and things like
that guys do vlogs don't know here we go
we go girls that you don't have to be go
guy whatever it is but like they'll do
that and they'll be on like The Today
Show or something like that in Australia
and they just like they don't have any
substance essentially nice people don't
even I've met a lot of them but yeah I'd
really like to see
TV kind of catch on to people like you
or like you know that people who are
just creating substantive content and
and just show everyone out there like us
even my parents they're like oh you're
on YouTube what's he doing but like
already now I'm doing a few things on TV
now this is a legitimate career and the
things that they get like no views at
all I get much more views online but
it's just ironic isn't it like that it's
just a different generation yeah what
was a man I truly am a fan and you know
thank you when modern education came out
I IDM do and I was like I'd love to get
young a show you were like I'll come to
America at some point yeah two years
later you're gonna we didn't thought we
could add it on an on skype but I'm glad
we did it yeah that wasn't okay Don
Scott yeah and I wish you a lot of luck
at but I have a feeling you know you
meet any luck I'll thank you very much
along the way man
I'm sorry thank you awesome all right
cool for more on Neil check out his
youtube channel at youtube.com slash me
okay that's ndel okay
[Music]
you